we're gonna fill in the heading once we
understand what these two problems are
okay so first I want to think about you
as a consumer okay you're a consumer
that means you know you're the kind of
person who's buying stuff from other
people and pay money for okay
that is a consumer we have a problem
okay there's stuff that we want the
stuff we want that we can't afford stuff
we can't afford it there's lots of stuff
that you probably want but you can't
afford come on give me some examples a
ratio a car thank you my renderable give
you another one sort of decide get a
tank okay Jacob a nice house excellent
okay so okay I'm gonna put those all
other than God we will talk about stuff
like that's big like businesses later on
but for now I'm thinking about like as a
consumer I'm gonna buy a business that
doesn't really make you a consumer that
makes you a business owner so we said we
said vehicles ranging from the expensive
to the somewhat ridiculously expensive
and we also said the homes
but even it's smaller stuff than that
like anything you go down to like say
Harvey Norman if you gotta buy sit like
a like a B TV saying right like how much
you guys ready this TV costs about a
thousand maybe depending on how good do
so okay so there you go there is an
interactive list on stuff we want but we
can't afford it okay and this is a
problem for us as consumers there's the
first problem you've got a whole bunch
of keys and then what stuff they can't
afford here's a second problem yeah
that's right I want you to uh put the
show the other foot down okay picture
yourself we've done this before right as
a retailer not a consumer who buy stuff
a retailer who sells stuff okay now
you've got all of these maybe you're a
oh you're a car salesman
Rijkaard ela or baby you own a harvey
norman you know store time that here's
the thing right you've got you've got
stuff you want to sell right but you
can't sell it
you can't sell stuff because people who
well they can't afford it kind of let me
explain what I mean people but afford it
and I'll put a Ford and maybe you should
put it for you know inverted commas
she's the idea right these days typical
salary you know if you're gonna if your
professional you're heading tens of
thousands of dollars per year right but
you still can't but just go out buy TV
or buy a car all those kinds of things
because they take a lot of money like in
a big chunk like sorry Chloe how much is
a Range Rover I know it's late give me
the examples 70 grand okay
do they go up from there is LA yeah yes
so so many greats like basic model now
Shh almost no one has access to just
seventy thousand dollars just sitting
there right it's a lot cool I'm just
ready with a VM redraw my $7000 right
goodbye
so here's what I mean right when we say
we cut off order it inverted commas
right it means I don't have access to
that big sum of money all at once maybe
over a period of time but we tend not to
be very good as a society like saving
money we tend to spend it fairly quickly
so here we go you're two problems one
from the consumers point of view and the
other from the retailer's point of view
and some guys some genius or maybe many
of them for off one solution that deals
it both of these problems at once they
don't know what it is yeah it's a game
you don't know if you have a difference
in a question the question is looking at
two problems right consumers want to buy
stuff kind of photo retail is able to
sell stuff but the people they want to
sell to it's a very narrow set of the
population it's like you're Keanu Reeves
you have millions of dollars but there's
a solution for
yeah aha okay now pan plate is perfect
phrase the texture gives it another
phrase which I'm going to put on it then
we'll prepare plan after that it's
called
buying or purchasing on terms no this is
the heady this is so this has lots of
other names so another example is a
payment claim right another thing that
this gets called is sometimes you say I
want to buy this on Finance or I'm gonna
get this financed right
even though Finance is a very broad word
that just means anything to do with
money right but they say and I'll show
you some examples in a second I'm gonna
buy this I'm gonna get it financed okay
this is what they mean really in some
ways it's just like a special kind of
loan and I'll explain how it works okay
here's the principle I want to purchase
it extension project let's go for let's
go for the Range Rover shall we I want
to buy one but I don't have the $70,000
just sitting around okay so here's what
I do I say to the to the dealership look
I promise promise okay that I will pay
you all of the money eventually okay if
you let me have the car now and let me
start driving it in fact not only will I
promise to pay you there's 70,000
dollars right
maybe I'll promise to pay a bit more
than 7-thousand say say something like
ninety thousand okay now just think
about this okay um that's an active big
job your money okay but it's actually
not that unusual as you'll see shortly
okay this is a win-win for both of us
can you see why to it why is it a win
for the consumer I get the car
I will not have seventy thousand dollars
for like years and years and years but I
get the car now and I get to use it
that's really good
why is it good for the retailer yeah
that's right he gets full money he gets
like a stream of income and not only
that it means he can sell stuff to a
much bigger group of people people who
don't necessarily have you know this
amount of money
around right but it's like all I can
afford a bit here and there like on a
regular payment sort of schedule and so
this is a win-win it solves both
problems
kind of